they come out after dark when the
municipal police have gone home and
claim a spot on the pavement because
it's the only way to make a living in
Zimbabwe so you are selling things
industries we need jobs
faced with an unemployment rate of 90
percent this country has become a nation
of street vendors with vegetables from
the garden and the sugar and the coffee
smuggled in from abroad as the public
desert the real economy this man's
trying to prevent its imminent collapse
Emerson Manager Gua inherited rampant
inflation food shortages and crippling
government debt after deposing autocrat
Robert Mugabe last year and he's asked
Mutulu in Cuba a former lecturer at the
London School of Economics to sort it
one is a package to be put together
build confidence external confidence in
terms of areas areas clears I want to
appoint an International Economic
Advisory Board of a million persons who
can help us the minister needs help but
he won't get it here Zimbabwe farmers
used to drive the economy generating
wealth and mass employment but the land
is less productive than it was Kennedy
Banda was given a share in this property
after it was seized from white farmers
in 2000 how many hectares of wheat have
you got planted but he says he couldn't
farm it on his own the government
provides him with seeds fertilizer and
tools through a special program every
you go
governments should subsidize agriculture
was this doorway with our prices of
fertilizers and to break even it to be
very very difficult
the problem is Zimbabwe can't afford to
support 600,000 smallholders that is the
government is basically broken it
doesn't have any money
vehicle to support agriculture
government is good to support
agriculture still no choice that the
idea is not choices even by his I see
Rob and Darrin smart ran a profitable
farm for decades and their employees
were overjoyed when the pair came to
take the property back six months
earlier they'd been thrown off it by a
member of the ruling party it was a
difficult time for everyone but the
smarts think they're safe under the new
regime the 'trust Managua as much as
he'd interesting ISM I think all these
little sort of things add up to hell of
a lot better than madhavi's day so yeah
we are better footing now than we were
say 12 months ago under Mugabe four
thousand white farmers were forcibly
removed but President Manning GOG WA is
offering them 99-year leases as an
inducement to return the atmosphere has
changed the other day we were invited by
the army come and enjoy a fun shoot with
us all the local farmers Helen Maga
beach day if we touch neikei we'd be
savored staging a coup so they gave us a
case it's a matter given up with it boys
you know this sort of thing there's not
this stigma that the whites are gonna
take over this country if they give them
something
it is necessity perhaps that's focused
minds in a fertile country that can't
feed itself but a new day in Zimbabwe is
a long way off John sparks Sky News in
Resaca Zimbabwe